[Music]
four thousand years ago the ancient
Sumerians made a surprising discovery if
they scraped the bark off a particular
kind of tree and ate it their pain
disappeared little did they know that
what they'd found was destined to
influence the future course of Medicine
what the Sumerians had discovered was a
precursor to the medicine known today as
aspirin aspirins active ingredient is
found commonly in willow trees and other
wild plants which is how it came to
infuse the medical traditions of Sumer
ancient Egypt ancient Greece and other
cultures
around 400 BC Hippocrates thought of as
the father of modern medicine first
recommended chewing willow bark for pain
relief and making willow leaf tea to
ease the pain of childbirth
but it took over two thousand years for
us to comprehensively investigate its
potential
in the mid 18th century an Englishman
named Edward stone ran five years of
experiments showing that willow bark
crushed into a powder and eaten could
cure a fever it took nearly another 70
years for a German pharmacist Johann
Buckner to finally identify and purify
the substance that made all this
possible
a compound called salicin
by then doctors were routinely using
willow bark and other Salus enriched
plants like the herb meadowsweet to ease
pain fever and inflammation but
identifying the exact compound suddenly
opened up the possibility of
manipulating its form in 1853 a French
chemist managed to chemically synthesize
the compound creating a substance called
acetyl salicylic acid then in 1897 the
pharmaceutical company Bayer found a new
method and began marketing the compound
as a pain reliever called aspirin this
was widely recognized as one of the
first synthetic pharmaceutical drugs
originally aspirin was just Bayers brand
name a for a settle and spur for
meadowsweet whose botanical name is
spiraea almería soon
aspirin became synonymous with acetyl
salicylic acid
as its influence grew aspirin was found
to ease not just pain but also many
inflammation related problems like
rheumatoid arthritis pericarditis which
inflames the fluid filled sac around the
heart and Kawasaki disease where blood
vessels become inflamed
yet despite aspirins medical value at
this point scientists still didn't
actually know how it worked in the 1960s
and 70s swedish and british scientists
changed that they showed that the drug
interrupts the production of certain
chemicals called prostaglandins which
control the transmission of pain
sensations and inflammation in 1982 that
discovery won the researchers a Nobel
Prize in medicine
over time research has also uncovered
aspirins risks overconsumption can cause
bleeding in the intestines and the brain
it can also trigger raise syndrome a
rare but often fatal illness that
affects the brain and liver in children
with an infection and in the late 20th
century aspirins success had been
overshadowed by newer painkillers with
fewer side effects like acetaminophen
and ibuprofen but in the 1980s further
discoveries about aspirins benefits
revived interest in it in fact the 1982
Nobel Prize winners also demonstrated
that aspirin slows production of
thromboxanes chemicals that cause
clumping of platelets which in turn form
blood clots a landmark clinical trial
showed that aspirin reduced heart attack
risk by 44 percent in participants who
took the drug today we prescribe it to
people at risk of heart attack or stroke
because it cuts the likelihood of clots
forming in the arteries that supply the
heart and brain
even more intriguingly there's a growing
body of research that suggests aspirin
reduces the risk of getting and dying
from cancer especially colorectal cancer
this might be due to aspirins
antiplatelet effects by reducing
platelet activity aspirin may decrease
the levels of a certain protein that
helps cancer cells spread these
discoveries have transformed aspirin
from a mere pain reliever to a
potentially life-saving treatment today
we consume about 100 billion aspirin
tablets each year and researchers
continue searching for new applications
already aspirins versatility has
transformed modern medicine which is
astounding considering its humble
beginnings in a scraping of willow bark
ted-ed
is a non-profit if you value our work
please consider supporting it on
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]